- When that opportunity
knocks, and you can become
something successful in life,
you got to push forward.
This [Censored] Ain't made for everybody.
You know what I'm saying? It's like
everybody ain't going
to be a [Censored] Star,
to be the [Censored].
Everybody ain't going to be what you are.
Just like when T-Pain came out.
T-Pain was the [Censored].
Then everybody took his auto-tune--
- And went with it.
- Now where is T-Pain?
- His music career began
in 1992 when he was
discovered by Dr. Dre of NWA.
He has since sold over 35
million albums worldwide.
In 2012 after a trip to Jamaica,
he announced a conversion
to the Rastafari movement
and a new alias, Snoop Lion.
He's Snoop Dogg, and here's my take on
his Top 10 Rules for Success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
Also if Snoop Dogg is talking
if he says something that
really means something to you,
please leave it in the comments
and put quotes around it
so other people can be
inspired as well. Enjoy.
(inspirational music)
- I just go back to that
time when I was young and
I didn't know what I wanted to do in life
and once I finally
grabbed a hold to what I
wanted to do which was this music thing.
And I loved every minute
of it, despite me not
being able to make money or have a career,
I had to believe in myself,
and I want to say that to
the youngsters out there
that's watching, you know.
Believe in anything that you believe in
but have the most believing in yourself
whether it's being a
doctor or a lawyer or a
chemist or whatever it is,
you have to believe yourself.
And once you believe,
the dream will come true
and the people will believe in you.
That's what dreams are made
of, you have to believe in it
and then a dream can come to life.
The advice that I would give
all of the rappers in the game
is to be original.
That's one thing about when I came out,
originality was a must.
You had to sound like
you, you had to be you
you had to have your own everything.
And I just feel that
there's a lot of, you know,
mimicking going on because it's a fad and
everybody feels like what's hot,
we're going to do what's hot
we're going to rap the same way,
we're going to rap over the same beats
as opposed to being different and dynamic
the way it was supposed to be and
that's what we're doing right now with the
Bush project, we're putting
something different out there.
It's not the bounce, it's a groove line.
- Yeah.
- We got a groove line with
this record right here, it's a groove
that only if you grown you
can find it real quick.
But if you're young
it'll take you a second
to catch up to it.
When that opportunity knocks,
and you can become
something successful in life
you got to push forward.
Like even with myself, I
had to make a decision when
I was a drug-dealing gang-banger.
Am I going to become a
rapper, and leave this behind
when I'm getting this money?
And this ghetto superstardom?
Or do I really want to
become a real star and
let that go, and push
it to the limit and say,
"I'm not finna eat, I'm
not finna get no money,
I'm not finna do nothing
but put my faith in this."
And I did and twenty-some years later,
I can say "alright, this
was a great decision."
My message would just be to
find peace within yourself.
Because once you find
peace within yourself
the energy that you get
usually is reflected.
And people get their energy off of you
that's what I've been
able to find, from being
on the negative energy
side as a young artist
to a grown man that projects
positive and peaceful music.
But it still has the energy
of the young spirit, so
it's all within the
same realm but it's just
finding yourself and being
able to be within yourself
and have peace, so that
way you can project peace.
Especially on the internet,
you can get pulled into
a whole lot of negative energy.
I've done things where
I put pictures up and
read comments and I say
something back and I end up
arguing with somebody
on the internet that I
don't even know.
I'm like, you pulled me
all the way out of my skin.
So it's just a point of knowing
your limitations as far
as where you're going
and let people take you out
of your frame of who you are.
I don't ever allow nobody
to take me out of the
mindstate that I'm supposed to be in,
know what I'm saying?
Never let them see me
sweat, never let them see me
deal with adversity as
if I can't deal with it.
But as you grow, you lose certain homies.
Because it's called, closing the gap.
This is the gap, when we start.
This is the gap as you grow.
Notice how you grow, and they don't?
So how do you close the gap?
You got to come back down.
When you come back down, you lose.
So you got to keep going up.
That's why closing the gap got to be them,
catching up to you.
And if they don't catch up,
you got to leave them behind!
Because you get to the
point now where you got to
start cutting out, know what I'm saying?
It's like, you can't look
back when you cut them out.
Because if they're meant to be there,
they going to be there--
- Forever.
- Yeah! 'Cause I had to cut out
family members before, me and my cousin
dads fell out before.
When me and him fell out it
was like, how do you fall out?
I taught you everything you know!
I put you in the game!
And you go against me?
But that's what the laws of the game do,
it puts you in a position
where sometimes you
have to have these types
of situations to see
who really supposed to be there.
- True indeed.
- This (censored) ain't
made for everybody,
you know what I'm saying?
It's like, everybody ain't
going to be a (censored) star,
everybody ain't going
to be the (censored).
Everybody ain't going to be what you are.
It was 60 niggas that you was rappin' with
and out of them 60,
you the (censored) one.
And you can go back and
try to help all 60 of them,
but guess what? Ain't
none of them going to
ever be you.
And I done it many times where I tried to
make niggas stars, and
rapped on they (censored),
took 'em on tour, and damn near
gave niggas my shoes, my
clothes, my everything!
You can have all- I can't make you a star.
Stars are born, they're not made.
Hear what I'm saying?
So it's like if you ain't
born one, you can't make one.
You can't take your energy
and put it into somebody
and make them what you are.
I had to cut a lot of niggas out there I
really felt like, "man,
I wonder how he doin'".
You know what, I can't
worry about how he doing
because if I worry about how he doing,
than I might miss a beat, and I might
miss my lines onstage and
they may not want to pay me
like they've been paying me.
- True indeed.
- I got to get this money.
- How would you describe your body of work
prior to this transformation?
- Gangsta.
(audience laughs)
- Now people will laugh
at that, but it really
isn't all that funny, is it?
- No it's not because it was more or less
the betrayal of what I
lived, and the life I lived
and the community that I came from.
I came from selling drugs,
being involved in a gang.
So most of my music was
representative of that,
but then once I became successful,
I strayed away from that
and became a business
and became who I am now,
so that's why the music
is more representative of who I am today.
- Now let me ask you a question:
Let's say that this music, that represents
more of who you are today
is not as successful as the music that
represented how you were years ago?
- It doesn't bother me.
I'm not doing it for financial
reasons or successful gain.
It's more about where I'm
speaking to facts and issues
for example the gun issue.
I have a song called "No
Guns Allowed" that speaks
directly to the issues of gun violence
because I feel like
that's real.
(audience applause)
- I think it would be
nice if that took hold
across the popular culture, really.
- Yeah and it starts with you.
You got to be the man
in the mirror to say,
"You know what? I'm going
to start with myself."
Through example, I believe
that people will follow.
I believe that the right
thing will be done,
because I'm one who used to lead people in
the wrong direction.
Now I'm leading them
in the right direction.
But I respect the youngsters,
I respect the movement
because it's a young
man's game and I've always
been like that.
That's why they call me "Uncle Snoop"
because I never disrespected them,
I've always treated them as my nephews.
Even if I didn't like they
(censored) I never told them,
"I don't like it", I'll tell them, look,
maybe you should try to be a
little bit more original and
not follow the fad.
Because the fad is only a fad.
That rap style is going
to play out in a minute.
But if it's yours, it's
going to live on forever.
Just like when T-Pain came out.
T-Pain was the (censored)!
And everybody took his auto-tune,
- And went with it.
- Now where's T-Pain?
- Where's his hair at?
He cut his (censored) off too!
- Because that's what the game do,
the game suck you dry.
It takes from you, you
know what I'm saying?
It's like the originals got to understand,
when you're original
you got to find ways to
diversify your portfolio.
In other words, meaning
that, how I always come back
with some different (censored),
I'm Snoop Dogg at all times but
I'm able to do this,
that, that, that and that to where it
finally comes back to the point to where
I started in 1992, it's 2015 and I'm still
on the radio talking to you, about an
album I got coming out that's relevant.
The best advice I can give
you is go make some noise,
you know?
These MC's right here was
doing they thing before
I got with them, that's
what made it easy for
me to get down with them.
I didn't have to teach them how to
be who they are.
You got to find out who you
are and be the best at that.
And once you master at
who you are and being
great at that, eventually
somebody like myself
will come across you and be able to
give you that opportunity.
Or you may just make it on your own!
Some stars are born,
you know, you don't need
people like me to make you when
you're a born star, so
I just want to inspire those out there
that are watching what we're doing,
seeing what we're doing, just look at the
positivity of what we're doing.
You have to practice over the years.
I wasn't great at the
beginning, I was aight.
And then I got cool, and then I got good.
Then I got better.
Then I got great.
Those are steps to becoming great.
And a lot of people ain't willing to
take those steps.
It takes ten years at
something continuously
to become great at it.
And I stuck with it
for ten years straight,
before I had a record
deal, before I had money
before I had lights and camera
before I had, you know,
people wanting to sit
down and interview me.
- So, Snoop, are you
ready to play with us now?
- I'm ready to get this money!
(audience laughs, applause)
- You know, you get one question
and if you get it
correctly, you get 50,000.
If you happen not to answer
it you'll get 25,000 anyway.
- Oh, so it's a win-win!
(audience laughs)
- It's a win-win,
you got that right!
(audience applauds)
You play trivia much?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Do you? Well you've got
one expert to help you,
his name is Ken Jennings, he's the top
trivia guy of all time. And you've got
on the lifelines as well.
So if you're all ready, Snoop,
we going to go for it, right now?
- I stay ready so I
ain't got to get ready.
- Okay fine!
Let's play Billionaire, with Snoop Dogg!
(audience cheers)
Okay, Snoop, here it is:
- Man I seen that movie too
and I feel asleep on it.
(audience laughs)
- Don't tell me that, Snoop!
You fell asleep, you got
$50,000 riding on this!
- Ah!
- Anybody wearing a
mask that you remember?
- I remember him wearing a mask,
I remember a little- things--
- Inkblots, yeah!
- I don't remember his name.
Can I ask the audience?
- You want to ask the
audience? Positively.
Go for it.
Audience, come on! Snoop needs
your help!
(audience cheers)
Audience!
On your keypads,
vote now.
- I think I know what it is.
They going to help me confirm the answer,
I think I know what it is.
I was asleep, I don't remember the name!
(audience cheers)
- 90 percent said "Rorshach" and before
the audience had a chance to answer.
While the voting was
going on, you said to me,
you think you know who it is.
- I thought it was him because when I was
asleep I kept hearing that name
(audience laughs)
- Must have been a very
exciting movie, huh?
- Yeah, definitely!
- So you think it's "Rorshach",
the audience thinks it's "Rorshach",
we're going to make it a final answer,
what are you going to say, Snoop?
- My final answer would be "D: Rorshach".
- Yes, Snoop!
(audience cheers)
$50,000 dollars!
Put it there, man! Snoopy!
Snoopy!
Put it there!
- I knew it!
50,000 baby, yeah!
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
John Micheal Musaazi
asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur that
you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do.
And I would also love to know,
what did you learn today from Snoop Dogg
that really resonated with you?
What was the most important
lesson that you're going
to take from this?
Please leave it in the comments.
I'm curious to find out.
Finally I want to give
a quick shout out to
@BestYouPRO.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
and tweeting out that
awesome picture as well.
I really, really, really,
really appreciate it.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- My key to success would be
doing to others as you
would have them do unto you.
Be respectful, make good music,
stay true to who you are.
Be different.
Be cunning.
Be original.
I believe those things
right there will give you
longevity, it will give you a long time
to do what you doing
because that creates a lane
of peace, prosperity, respect and love.
And that will be honored by time
and your legacy will be
evaluated in due time.
- I got to ask you.
Did you ever meet and spend
any time with Michael Jackson?
- Yeah, me and Mike got a song together.
I don't know if it ever came out.
- I'm telling you right now it did not,
(laughs)
because I would've
already known if it did.
When did that happen?
- It was some sort of project he was doing
and what was crazy was
he called me, so to hear
his voice on the phone,
he was like,
"Hey, it's Michael!"
I'm like, "What's happenin', cuz?"
He was like, "Well first
of all, my mom says
you look like someone in my family,
we could be related."
I'm like, "Serious, cuz? What
you need me to do, Mike?"
(impersonating Michael Jackson)
"I have this particular
track and I want you to sing on it and
just do whatever you want to do."
I'm like, "Aight, cuz,
I'm going to handle that.
I'll get back at you, cuz."
And that was a conversation
with Snoop Dogg
and Michael Jackson!
(group laughs)
- That was it!
- I went to work.
You know I wasn't about all that talking,
come on, Rosenberg!
I was infatuated, when
I hung up I was like,
"Nigga you know who I was just
on the phone with, nigga?!
(group laughs)
Nigga that was
Michael Jackson, nigga!
Not Jermaine, nigga!
Not Joe!"
- Not Tito!
- "Nah that was Michael!"
- Did you ever see him in person?
- Yeah!
There was a dude named Christian Audigier.
He had that clothing line, I forgot--
- Ed Hardy.
- Yes.
- L.A. Talk!
Here comes more
- Say that! Say that!
- Yeah yeah, it's a
big thing--
- He was a boss!
He would spend like,
three or four hundred thousand dollars
to have you come perform
like, three songs.
It would be me, Michael Jackson,
whoever else, whoever else.
And Michael Jackson's trailer
was right next to mine.
And we was blowin' like a broke stove.
And Mike opened the
curtain and looked on and
said, "Hi Snoop!"
I said (imitates smoking) "You
want to hit somethin', Mike?"
(laughs)
(imitates Michael Jackson) "No thank you!"
(group laughs)
- That really happened?
- Yes sir!
- Alrighty so what we going
to do right now, Vic One,
let's bless him with a
instrumental of his own!
So we can go ahead and get
something live from Snoop Dogg
up in here.
You remember this one here, Dogg?
- Yeah
- Mmmhmm!
- You want something new
or something old on this?
- Man, I want "Gin & Juice"!
♫ "With so much drama in the LBC
♫ It's kind of hard being
Snoop D-o-double-G, but I
♫ Somehow, some way
♫ Keep coming up with funky,
funky, funk-funky, funky
♫ With so much drama in the LBC
♫ It's kind of hard being
Snoop D-o-double-g, but I
♫ Somehow someway, keep coming up with
♫ Funky-Ass hits like every single day
♫ May, I
♫ Kick a little somethin' for the G's
♫ And, make a few ends
as I breeze, through
♫ It's 2 in the morning and
the party's still jumpin
♫ 'cause my Mama ain't home
♫ I got some chickens in the--
♫ Gettin' it on and
they ain't leavin' 'til
♫ Six in the morning
♫ So what you want to do? Ungh.
♫ I got a pocket full of 'em
and Big Boy he got some too
♫ We don't love them-
♫ So we gon' blow an
♫ G's up, freeze up for a
second now bounce to this."
I even put the Radio Version on for ya.
(group laughs)
- That fine and heavy!
- It really is.
- You know!
- Yes sir.
♫ We just rollin' down the
street, smokin' smokin' smokin'
♫ Sippin' on gin & juice
♫ Laid back
♫ With my mind on my money and
♫ Now, that, I got me some Seagram gin
♫ Everybody got they cups
but they ain't chipped in
♫ Now this types of hit
♫ Happens all the time
♫ You got to get yours,
big, I got to get mine
♫ Everything is fine,
when you're listening to
♫ 92.3, not point but the real for me
♫ Snoopy D-o-double-g I come off the dome
♫ Get you, crackin' and
rappin' and all alone
♫ Sit back, relax, let
me show you how it's
♫ Supposed to be
♫ I do it to you everyday, 92 threezy
♫ I'm the realest, you feel this
♫ You can't push punch 'cause
♫ Snoopy D-o-double-g
I'm the top of the bunch
♫ And Captain Crunch,
what I eat for breakfast
♫ And I get my mind
right, jump in my Lexus
♫ And I head on a trip,
just to get my grip"
And say what up to Big Boy
What up, Crip?!
- Hellooooooo!
(group exclaims)
Alright, man, we got to go
with the shizz right now, man.
- Oh for that one?
- We got to go
with the shizz right now.
- Come on.
- Alright, here we go!
Awwwwww
- Okay.
- Shizz
- Let me visualize
this one right here.
- Go ahead now, Dogg, go ahead boy.
- This was the one that said,
(singing)
- That's how we do it.
- Turn me up a little bit
♫ "Popping, stopping,
hopping like a rabbit
♫ When I take the Nina Ross
ya know I gots to have it
♫ I stay back in the cut retain myself
♫ Think about the hit,
and I'm thinking wealth
♫ Now how can I make my grip
♫ And how can I make
this sucka straight slip
♫ Set trip, I got to get him for his grip
♫ As I dip around the corner
♫ Now I'm on another
mission, wishin, upon a star
♫ Snoop Doggy Dogg with the caviar
♫ In the back of the limo
no demo, this is the real
♫ I'm breakin' you all down
like Evander Holyfield, chill
♫ To the next episode
♫ I make money, and I really don't love-
♫ Give you the truth, I swoop in the Coupe
♫ I used to sell loot,
I used to shoot hoops
♫ But now I make, hits, every single day
♫ With, my homie, the diggy Dr. Dre
♫ So lay back in the cut,
♫ Young buster, 'fore you get shot
♫ It's 187 on you all and the Cops."
(singing)
Big Boy, you on point!
♫ "It's getting hot, yes indeed it is
♫ Big Boy is on the mic
he 'about to go for his
♫ S n double o and to the P that's me
♫ Break it down for you do it so viciously
♫ I can't spit that rap,
I got to get this rap
♫ I got to hit that
trap, I got hit that lick
♫ I got to get that grip,
I got sip that drank.
♫ I got to make that move,
I got to roll that dank
♫ I got to lay low and show
'em how the West Coast go.
♫ Big Boy back on the radio
♫ Snoop Dogg came through,
I heard a beat and quick
♫ I said, you better
let me get a verse on it
♫ He said, cool, he said, pause
♫ He said, Dogg, you the
best and you break laws
♫ And you come through and you come hard
♫ And you come raw
♫ Snoop Dogg's the coldest MC
♫ you ever saw
- Awwww!
(singing)
- And this is the real, 92-3
L.A.'s Hiphop and R&B.
- Alright man, the one and only
Snoop Dogg!
- It is what it is!
(group cheers)